pasemos a la revista de prensa con Marta
Moya en directo a América Marta Buen día
para usted Hola Ángela buenos días
Estamos a pocos días de la coronación el
del Rey Carlos III y abrimos esta
revista de prensa con una exclusiva
desde Garden que vincula la corona
británica con la compra de personas
esclavizadas africanas desde el estado
de Virginia no es casualidad que salga
esta noticia no Ángela no es casualidad
de que todo esto se debe cuando el 6 de
mayo se va a producir la coronación de
Carlos III de hecho esta nueva
investigación de de Guardian viene a
colación de otra que se dio a principios
del mes de abril cuando se vinculó en
otra investigación directamente a la
línea de sucesión de Windsor con el
tráfico de esclavos africanos esta nueva
entrega dice que un
familiar directo de Carlos III habría
comprado
200 personas esclavizadas en el estado
de Virginia en una planta Tabacalera
todo este hallazgo no nace
exclusivamente de de Guardian sino que
nace a través de una dramaturga
concretamente de desiree baptice que
estaba haciendo una investigación para
hacer una obra de teatro trazando esos
vínculos entre el esclavismo en Virginia
y la iglesia en Inglaterra en estos
documentos se dice publicados por de
Guardian se dice a un capitán que
entrega 200 africanos esclavizados de la
compañía Royal african Company a
Inglaterra y además hay que destacar que
esta compañía ya venía Traficando con
casi 180.000 personas esclavizadas en
África Carlos III Al Calor de todas
estas investigaciones dijo que es una
atrocidad espantosa sin embargo no dijo
nada sobre los vínculos o la
responsabilidad directa que tiene la
corona con el esclavismo africano
perteneciente al estado de Virginia
Ángela No claro Es que esto es parte de
la historia no Y la monarquía más
popular del mundo precisamente ese
llamada a rendir cuentas nos
cuestionamos cada vez más estos vínculos
coloniales con la corona y no solamente
esta imagen institucional que da del
Reino Unido no Aunque eso Por supuesto
no va a cambiar nada de la coronación al
menos en el futuro inmediato Pero al
menos Sí vale la pena hacer una
reflexión alrededor que funcionarios del
Palacio de buckingham dijeron que el Rey
Carlos no se puede pronunciar mucho más
allá de este tema hasta después de que
se corone no que también es algo obvio y
que tampoco se pronunciará seguramente
Marta Pero entonces vamos a Estados
Unidos a cambiar de tema porque
continúan los secos de esta polémica
sobre el repentino despido de toker
carlson Este es un tema que hemos
querido abordar hace varios días uno de
los presentadores estrella de la cadena
Fox news que decidió romper con él justo
después de pagar una compensación
millonaria a una empresa de conteo de
votos que lo había acusado de difundir
noticias falsas de todo esto en el marco
electoral de las pasadas elecciones
entre Donald Trump y Joe biden si Ángela
y lo queríamos tratar pero al final Joe
biden se interpuso Nuestro camino el
pasado martes cuando presentó su
candidatura a la reelección el New York
Times publica este jueves un artículo
que dice que
Fox news se enteró un día antes de que
empezara este juicio por difamación
contra la cadena por la Que pagó
recordemos casi 800 millones de dólares
a la empresa dominion System y un día
antes de que empezara ese ese juicio la
cadena se enteró de que carlson había
hecho unos comentarios totalmente fuera
de lugar unos comentarios privados a los
que tenían acceso los abogados pero que
los altos directivos de la cadena no
conocieron hasta un día antes de que se
produjera el inicio de ese juicio esto
es sorprendente porque los abogados
llevan meses teniendo esos mensajes en
su poder unos mensajes que no han
trascendido pero que fueron según este
artículo del New York Times
determinantes para que carlson fuera
despedido el pasado lunes en la junta
directiva de Fox news recordemos
descubrió los mensajes del lunes y lo
despidió con un mensaje muy escueto en
el que le agradecía sus servicios pero
que al final es una gran pérdida para
Fox news porque carlson era una de las
grandes estrellas que daba además unos
ratings de audiencia espectaculares a la
Fox news y por otra parte hemos
destacado una exclusiva de la revista
Rolling Stones que dice que ocho fuentes
de dentro y de fuera de la cadena de la
Fox news dicen que tenían un expediente
que podría comprometer ataque el Carson
si decide irse en contra de la cadena
después de su de su despido Además este
documento incluiría quejas internas
sobre la conducta en el lugar de trabajo
además de comentarios despectivos
misóginos racistas tóxicos contra la
gerencia y contra los propios colegas de
la cadena un portavoz de Fox news ha
negado que exista el expediente en
contra de clarson pero desde otras
fuentes de la cadena dicen que esto es
una práctica habitual dentro de Fox
cuando sus empleados quieren irse contra
la cadena igual es que ya lo hemos dicho
antes cuando salió esta demanda y
estábamos esperando que sucediera un
juicio Fox news al final paga siempre
tiene este tipo de prácticas para
resolver sus líos legales sin decir que
toca el Carson sea o no inocente pero no
lo sabremos Simplemente no lo sabremos
porque se resuelve todo tras bambalinas
Marta y vamos a cerrar con una editorial
de The economista Porque mientras se
Fragua la esperada contra ofensiva en
Ucrania esta revista dice que occidente
debería posicionarse definitivamente a
favor de entregar aviones de combate a
kiev y aquí sigue este ir y venir de
entrega de armamento de Ucrania Así es
Ángela y a ver esto se refiere
concretamente a Estados Unidos no dice
que Estados Unidos tiene que enviar
cazas f-16 a Ucrania ante la esperada
contra que no sabemos cuándo va a llegar
exactamente el no envío de aviones por
parte de occidente concretamente de
Estados Unidos dice este editorial di
economist es solo una excusa mientras
Ucrania pierde parte de sus sistemas de
defensa terrestre y Rusia tiene cinco
veces más la capacidad de atacar por
aire que Ucrania con los sistemas
actuales occidente debería replantearse
su decisión de no enviar cazas de guerra
los argumentos de occidente son
potenciar la defensa terrestre con el
envío de los tanques Además de que el
entrenamiento de los pilotos de aviones
llevaría más de un año por tanto no
sería efectivo y sobre todo el argumento
principal es que esto podría generar una
escalada de las tensiones con Rusia sin
embargo dice este editorial de
dieconomics que este argumento de la
escalada no funciona porque lo que
podría hacer es pasar un mensaje a Putin
de que el compromiso de occidente con
kiev es inquebrantable Ángela eso dice
di economist y entre tanto nosotros nos
preguntamos hasta cuándo podrán tener
fondos de financiación para seguir
entregando armas a Ucrania y hasta
cuándo se podrá prolongar la guerra
gracias a usted Marta y nos veremos
mañana Gracias